as marijuana becomes legal eyes
throughout North America many are trying
edibles for the first time as a
healthier option but with edible
marijuana providing such a different
experience than smoking how does it work
end is eating pot actually better for
you when you heat cannabis you
effectively change the chemical makeup
of compounds within it called
cannabinoids smoking heats it to around
800 degrees Celsius and converts THC a
to Delta 9 THC which binds to receptors
in your brain making them continually
fire and causing your imagination that
thoughts and perceptions to magnify this
is why every thought can feel like a
significant one and because it travels
straight from your lungs into the
bloodstream and to your brain the drug
works within minutes and lasts about two
to three hours but when making edibles
the weed is heated to around 150 degrees
Celsius running less of the actual plant
and minimizing carcinogens THC is
lipophilic not water-soluble so the
activated THC must be dissolved into
something fatty like oil or butter and
once this substance is consumed the
onset of the high is delayed as the drug
is absorbed more slowly through your gut
but this high typically lasts forward to
eight hours and most report feeling more
high than compared to smoking marijuana
this is because when you eat edible weed
the THC is first metabolized by the
liver before entering the bloodstream
and here Delta 9 THC also becomes 11 o
HT HT which passes the brain barrier
more rapidly and is a more potent
chemical so using the same amount of
marijuana you actually get more high
with edibles because it ends up creating
both Delta 9 THC and 11 o h th G which
is a stronger compound and because there
are more psychotropic types of
cannabinoids acting on your neurons
you'll be high for longer of course you
also get to skip out on the toxic
chemicals that smoking provides like
carbon monoxide bronchial irritants and
tumor initiators smoking anything means
you're inhaling cancer-causing molecules
so if you can get high without smoking
it will be healthier for your lungs and
body the downside it's much harder to
control the high oget because it can
take up to one to two hours to feel the
full effects and the dosage can vary
significantly modulating the effects or
titrating as it's called is much more
difficult and as a result you can end up
a lot higher than
intended to but unlike those who consume
too much alcohol opioids or other drugs
you won't be suffering any serious
long-term harm toxicity or lethal
overdose if you do consume more than you
intended if you've ever wondered why
marijuana gives you the munchies check
out our ASAP thought video that breaks
down the science behind that by clicking
the screen or using the link in the
description and subscribe for more
weekly science videos every Thursday